Traduttore: Maurizio Berti
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Cosa vuol dire essere senza parole?
Ecco, io oggi sono qui a raccontarvi
come abbiamo potuto aiutare Chiara
a trovare le parole
per esprimere quel mondo interiore
che lei aveva, ma non riusciva a dire.
Perché c'è una bella differenza
tra non avere niente da dire,
e volerlo dire, ma non avere
le parole per esprimerlo.
Chiara è nata 22 anni fa,
con un problema cognitivo e comunicativo.
Cosa vuole dire essere senza le parole
ve lo dico con un momento
di vita quotidiana:
a, a, a, e, e, e...
Noi eravamo a tavola,
Chiara ha iniziato ad agitarsi,
e io, da bravo papà, le volevo insegnare
che si sta a tavola
finché non si ha finito di mangiare.
Chiara ha continuato ad agitarsi,
io ho alzato la voce...
Noi adulti siamo forti.
Lei ha mosso il dito
e mi ha indicato in terra,
dove c'era la forchetta.
Bastava una parola,
semplice, che Chiara aveva dentro:
me l'ha indicata, quella forchetta.
Chiara ha sempre avuto
una capacità enorme
di sfruttare tutto quello
che ha a disposizione
- ha usato il dito -
e una voglia di esserci... e si agitava.
Ma questo non è bastato:
e così, a quattro anni,
abbiamo conosciuto
la comunicazione aumentativa.
Comunicazione aumentativa
sono tutte quelle pratiche
che permettono a una persona
di poter ridurre
il suo deficit comunicativo,
anch'io ho un chiaro deficit comunicativo
che è l'emozione,
e poter aumentare le sue potenzialità.
Per noi, comunicazione aumentativa
ha voluto dire soprattutto
comunicazione con i simboli.
Qua vedete una frase
che piace molto a Chiara:
"la forza sia con te".
Insieme alle parole ci sono dei simboli,
e questi simboli permettono a Chiara
di capire meglio quelle parole
che vengono dette.
Tutto è racchiuso dentro a un riquadro
che rende vicine
queste due modalità comunicative,
e quando parliamo con Chiara
indichiamo il riquadro:
"la – forza – sia – con – te".
Questo rende più chiaro
il fatto che il simbolo
e la parola siano uniti,
ma fa anche una cosa
molto più importante:
non chiediamo a Chiara
di entrare in un mondo
in cui lei non saprebbe comunicare;
ma noi ci avviciniamo al suo mondo,
siamo noi a comunicare con lei
e siamo noi a insegnarle,
nella sua modalità,
come poter comunicare con noi.
Ecco, questo è un momento
di comunicazione quotidiana.
Adesso iniziamo a raccontarvi la storia,
con un breve filmato.
"Cà - felice - delfino
- scivola - sul - fiume"
"... e - divento - grande"
La nostra storia è un po'
come questo fiume,
che Chiara ha descritto
con queste belle parole.
Un fiume che ci ha emozionato,
anche spaventato
- io ero piuttosto spaventato
di essere ribaltato lì in mezzo -
per poi finire con un tuffo
in una nuova dimensione:
l'età adulta,
che stiamo vivendo in questi giorni.
Anche la presenza qui
della persona che è stata
il motore di tutto questo,
della persona che ha voluto
mettersi in gioco fino in fondo,
fa parte di questo percorso
del diventare adulti,
di assumersi le responsabilità,
di poter dire quello che uno è.
Quando ho chiesto a Chiara
di essere presente in questo momento,
all'inizio lei è partita tutta carica;
nella seconda prova
si è fermata un attimo,
e ha detto che aveva bisogno
di un momento per pensare.
Parliamo di cose grosse.
Parliamo di una voce
che non riesce ad esprimersi.
Parliamo della sua voglia
di esserci in modo diverso.
Sono passati cinque minuti,
Chiara è venuta da me,
emozionata come sono io adesso,
e mi ha detto che c'era,
che lei è forte come Batman.
Chiara Errani!
Chiara, vieni qua un attimo.
Allora...
Chiara è espertissima di palcoscenico,
sapeva già quale fosse la sua postazione,
perché Chiara non userà oggi la voce,
ma usa il suo modo di comunicare:
indicando i simboli.
Le parole che voi vedete,
alcune le abbiamo scelte insieme,
altre - vi dirò io quali sono -
sono proprio le espressioni di Chiara,
che lei ha scritto
con la sua tabella di comunicazione,
e adesso vi dirà con le sue parole
che cos'è la tabella di comunicazione.
Vai!
Ecco: abbiamo problemi di altezza,
e allora
l'ausilio è importante
anche in questo caso:
comunicazione aumentativa.
Ci siamo?
(Applausi)
Cos'è la tabella di comunicazione?
"È – la – mia – voce"
Manca il simbolo,
ne parleremo dopo, eh Chiara?
Non aggiungerei altro
a questa definizione,
ma passerei a vedere in pratica
la storia di questa tabella.
"un – quaderno – che – mi
– portavo – in – ogni... ",
manca anche lì,
"... – posto"
Allora, [ecco ]la prima tabella di Chiara:
una serie di fogli divisi
per categorie, piene di simboli.
È lassù in cima...
non ci arriviamo, Chiara?
Ecco, vai...
Piena di simboli, comodissima:
tutti i simboli si vedono...
[ma] ingombrante,
non potevamo usarla in spiaggia.
Allora così siamo passati a un quaderno,
un quaderno che possiamo portare ovunque.
Ma ben presto,
come vedete nell'ultima immagine,
anche quello diventa troppo ingombrante.
Bisogna portare in giro
quasi un'enciclopedia.
E così, grazie alla tecnologia,
che anno dopo anno ci ha accompagnato,
è arrivato un altro strumento:
il tablet.
Problemi di spazio? Finiti.
Ma il tablet aveva permesso un'altra cosa
che all'inizio io credevo
che potesse essere quasi una magia.
Chiara, ti ricordi
all'inizio con il quaderno?
Per parlare bisognava andare
avanti e indietro.
E non era facile:
ma il problema non era di Chiara..
Ragazza vanitosa, la Chiara.
Il problema non era di Chiara:
ma era della persona
che comunicava con lei,
intanto doveva capire che quel quaderno
era uno strumento di comunicazione,
non "ma che bel quadernino
pieno di disegni..";
e poi, come funzionasse quello strumento
Chiara lo sapeva molto bene, l'altro no.
Ma la frase che voleva dire Chiara,
lei ce l'aveva dentro,
l'altro non lo sapeva.
E doveva ricordarsi i simboli
che velocissimamente
Chiara segnava sul suo quaderno,
andando avanti e indietro
per le categorie.
Dopo, col tablet,
la comunicazione è cambiata,
Chiara vi racconta di una zuffa
tra il coniglio King e il coniglio Cherry,
e di come si è sentita lei.
"Coniglio"
"Cherry"
"io triste"
"Coniglio Cherry ferita
a coniglio King - io triste"
Per la prima volta,
Chiara poteva comporre le sue frasi
e poteva dirle con una voce
che decideva lei
quando fare uscire e come,
con la sintesi vocale del tablet.
È stato un passaggio enorme:
ma qui dentro a questo strumento
c'era un'altra potenzialità grandissima:
la tastiera alfabetica.
Io non riuscirò mai a mettere
tutti i simboli che servono a Chiara
dentro a quella tabella.
Con la tastiera alfabetica
posso scrivere qualsiasi parola:
ma Chiara doveva imparare a scrivere.
Vai!
Ci arrivi... ci arrivi...
"I – libri – mi – piacciono – molto"
"mi – piacciono – i – loro – racconti"
Cosa c'entrano i libri?
Nei libri per Chiara c'erano
quei racconti importantissimi, bellissimi,
una sua passione.
Allora, come leggerli?
Prendendoli, copiandoli nel computer
dove un software associa
alle parole i simboli,
e con la sintesi vocale
Chiara li poteva leggere,
e li poteva stampare
e leggere con gli altri.
E così, scrivendole e copiandole,
le parole sono entrate dentro Chiara,
si è appropriata di quelle parole.
Le prime parole che Chiara ha scritto
in modo autonomo sono state:
Anakin Skywalker;
Gandalf; la torre; il principe,
E poi le parole del suo quotidiano:
la Nanà, il suo gatto; la Nasca;
il papà Luca, la mamma Claudia
e la sorella Elisa.
E così, siamo passati pochi giorni fa
a un nuovo strumento,
uno strumento
che avete tutti voi in tasca.
Giusto?
Adesso Chiara non ce l'ha
in tasca, l'ha dato a me.
Lo faccio vedere?
Vengo lì...
Eccolo qua, il nuovo strumento di Chiara.
(Applausi)
Ed ecco come parla Chiara adesso:
"Luca"
"andiamo"
"merenda"
"festa"
"Io – papà – Luca – andiamo
– merenda – festa"
Sì, stiamo andando.
Ecco: uno smartphone, una tastiera,
la predizione, la sintesi vocale,
tutta roba che potete scaricare
anche voi sul vostro cellulare.
Chiara adesso comunica
con questo strumento,
ma ha capito anche
che la sua comunicazione
attraverso questo strumento
può aprirsi molto di più.
E così manda i messaggi alle sue amiche:
il gatto Nasca con la nave spaziale...
Allora, cosa vuol dire essere grande?
Vai.
"Ma – cosa – vuol dire – essere – grande?"
Una foto di ragazze grandi.
Una foto importante per Chiara,
perché è testimonianza di un'amicizia
iniziata nei banchi delle elementari,
e ancora tutt'oggi presente.
Ma è una foto importante anche perché
quell'incontro chi l'ha organizzato?
Chi è che ha mandato i messaggi?
Tu!
E così a me, ignaro
(Applausi)
è arrivato un messaggio
sul cellulare che diceva:
"Domenica alle 7.30
veniamo a prendere Chiara,
andiamo in pizzeria
e poi veniamo da voi a vedere un film"
Be', direi che ci siamo:
hai capito come funziona il cellulare,
siamo diventati adulti.
Ecco: cosa vuol dire essere grandi,
ve lo dice anche Chiara con le sue parole:
"Quando - esco - con - i - miei - amici"
"ascoltiamo - musica
- e - guardiamo - film"
"con - la - tabella di comunicazione
- scriviamo - racconti"
"con - il - cellulare"
Scusate ...
"scrivo - a - tutti
- e - sono - molto - felice."
Ecco, la storia finisce qua:
speriamo di avervi dato qualche stimolo,
perché quando incontrate
delle persone che non parlano,
non pensiate che non hanno niente da dire,
o che non hanno un pensiero.
Tutti abbiamo un pensiero da comunicare,
tutti abbiamo un mondo interiore
da condividere,
e proprio grazie alle differenze di ognuno
può arricchire tutti quanti.
"Tutti – hanno – diritto – di – provare".
Non siamo speciali,
non siamo nati imparati.
Tutti hanno diritto di provare,
perché Chiara possa raccontare
a Tiziana un libro.
Tutti hanno diritto di provare,
come Chiara qua,
a fare quello che hanno in testa.
Eravamo ad un open-day di una palestra,
c'erano tantissimi sport,
Chiara ha visto dei ragazzi arrampicare
e voleva andare ad arrampicare.
Io e la mamma eravamo terrorizzati,
pensando a Chiara, con la sua disabilità,
appesa a una parete,
alta 12 metri, con un filo.
Lei è testarda,
ci ha fatto capire
che aveva tutti i diritti di provare,
e voleva provare.
Sono otto anni che Chiara arrampica.
Il giorno dell'arrampicata
è un giorno molto importante,
nella settimana.
Ma ha mosso anche a me la curiosità,
e allora ho pensato che anche io,
nonostante la mia pancia,
avessi diritto di provare
a fare arrampicata.
E mi sto proprio divertendo.
Tutti hanno diritto di provare,
ma per provare
bisogna avere gli strumenti.
"Per – una – comunicazione
– libera – per – tutti"
Mancano delle parole
perché abbiamo scelto
di fare questa presentazione
con questo sistema di simboli, "ARASAAC",
nato da un progetto
di una Università aragonese.
È un progetto di simboli open-source,
si possono scaricare
gratuitamente da Internet.
Va sviluppato: stiamo cercando
di creare un gruppo
per poter sviluppare
questo sistema di simboli.
Chiara, tu tutti i giorni
usi questi simboli?
No.
Chiara ha un altro sistema di simboli,
ma è coperto da copyright,
per cui vorremmo che un progetto
possa permettere
una comunicazione libera
a tutti, in ogni momento.
"Ma - la - cosa - più - importante"
La cosa che forse
vi avremmo dovuto dire prima,
perché sta prima di tutto;
ma vi diciamo adesso,
perché è quella che vogliamo
che voi vi ricordiate.
Potete dimenticare tutto ciò
che vi abbiamo detto finora,
ma questo no.
"Importantissimo - è - ascoltare."
Non c'è comunicazione se non c'è ascolto.
Tutti hanno diritto di essere ascoltati,
ma per essere ascoltati
bisogna che anche noi
ci muoviamo, cambiamo.
Oggi tutti voi avete fatto un cambiamento,
avete rotto dei ritmi.
La nostra non è stata
una presentazione classica:
ci siamo fermati,
abbiamo dato spazio a Chiara
di poter dire, di poter parlare
in un modo che è diverso,
un po' strano, più lento.
Per ascoltare, bisogna dare all'altro
il tempo e il modo di comunicare.
Bisogna dargli gli strumenti.
Bisogna avere la pazienza di aspettare
che l'altro finisca di parlare,
e non di dare noi le risposte
perché pensiamo di sapere già
cosa ci vuole dire.
Io devo ascoltare,
Chiara deve ascoltare,
e vi chiediamo da oggi
di prestare anche voi
una maggior attenzione ad ascoltare.
Grazie.
(Applausi)